bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors quelles vont être les
effets immédiats de ce grec cite
notamment pour les français établis à
londres
alors tout d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'effet immédiat c'est celui d'une
immense tristesse pour tous les pro
européens de voir cette aventure humaine
exceptionnelle de 47 en liaison avec nos
amis britanniques qui s'achève alors
bien sûr les britanniques resteront nos
amis mais il va falloir dès demain
retravaillée de manière très rigoureuse
à une nouvelle robe à la refondation de
l'europe et surtout aux négociations
avec le royaume uni
parce que rien n'est joué encore nous
savons une seule chose le royaume uni
est sorti de l'union européenne
malheureusement mais c'est maintenant
que les choses difficiles commencent par
ce qu'il va falloir commencer des
négociations il ya beaucoup de domaines
dans lesquels nous ne voyons pas ait
ouailles comme disent les britanniques
je pense par exemple à la pêche qui
allaient droit de libre circulation
mais pour répondre plus précisément à
votre question
pour le moment rien ne change puisque
nous avons obtenu cette période de
transition d'une année rien ne change
pour les citoyens européens qui vivent
en france et pour les français qui
vivent les européens qui vivent au
royaume uni en dehors du fait que bien
évidemment les britanniques qui étaient
sur des listes européennes en france ne
pourront pas être candidats ou voter
lors des élections municipales en france
et ce sera très probablement bien sur la
meme chose au royaume uni mais sinon on
pourra continuer à se rendre en grande
bretagne avec un passeport une carte
d'identité française sans formalité
autre que celle que nous avions
auparavant
alors on le rappelle une période de
transition et s'ouvre jusqu'à la fin de
l'année durant laquelle le royaume uni
européennes vont devoir négocier leur
divorce à proprement parler donc leurs
relations futures vous l'avez dit ces
relations
elles s'annoncent ces négociations
s'annoncent ardues selon vous quel
accord commercial
l'union européenne doit négocier avec
l'ombre à habas il y en a beaucoup on
nous devons négocier dans quasiment tous
les domaines mais je mentionnais tout à
l'heure un dossier qui est très
préoccupant pour nous qui est celui de
la pêche vais moi même présidé une
réunion au sénat sur la pêche entre
france union européenne et grande
bretagne
là nous avons un véritable problème une
vraie inquiétude à ce qu'il y a toujours
eu des tensions extrêmement fort avec
l'angleterre avec le les îles
anglo-normandes vous savez qu'il y à des
quotas qui ont été instaurées par
l'union européenne qui sont rejetés par
les pêcheurs britannique mais nous
français nous pêchons essentiellement
autour des côtes britanniques donc il
faut absolument qu'il y ait un accord
de la même manière que les britanniques
vont transformer leurs poissons en
france essentiellement mais nous devons
trouver un accord parce que c'est toute
la filière de la pêche en france qui
seraient menacés s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord commercial avec le royaume uni
ça me paraît vraiment prioritaire bien
évidemment il ya la question des
citoyens européens parce que c'est vrai
pour nous qui vivent comme moi qui vit
en grande-bretagne depuis plus trente
ans c'est vrai que c'est un choc
considérable et il faut obtenir le
symbole scatter et j'encourage
d'ailleurs tous nos citoyens européens
en grande bretagne à le demande et parce
que c'est essentiel nous avons un petit
peu plus de temps mais il faut quand
même s'en occuper très vite d'un gros
selon vous à quoi va ressembler ni
européenne à présent un sens le royaume
uni
alors c'est une très grande tristesse
bien évidemment parce que les
britanniques étaient très présents ils
contribuer beaucoup aux débats il était
sérieux comme ils le sont toujours dans
leurs débats cela va nous poser aussi un
problème de financement parce que
n'oublions pas que le royaume uni est un
contributeur net aux finances de l'union
européenne donc il va falloir trouver
maintenant 12 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an et cela pose de
grandes questions et des inquiétudes
pour vous donner un simple exemple le
fonds européen de défense qui avait été
décidée en 2017 et qui était une très
belle innovation risque de se voir
amputer de moitié puisque la présidence
finlandaise a déjà annoncé une réduction
de 6 millions propose une réduction de 6
millions de ce fonds européen de défense
donc il faut que nous soyons extrêmement
vigilant et il faut surtout que nous
travaillons à refonder l'europe parce
que je crois que c'est aussi une
opportunité jc d'être optimiste comme
toute personne politique devrait l'est
nous devons travailler à faire une
europe à la construire de manière à ce
qu'elle soit beaucoup plus proche des
citoyens de leurs préoccupations avec
moins de bureaucratie
nous devons aller de l'avant mais je
suis persuadé que nous allons continuer
à développer cette europe qui a été une
réalisation magnifique pour tous les
pays membres pour tous les citoyens et
nous irons de l'avant tout en gardant
bien évidemment des liens étroits avec
nos applis britannique qui restent nos
amis et nos partenaires nous avons
tellement de position commune merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le train de réagir
sur notre antenne joëlle garriaud-maylam
sénatrice les républicains des français
de l'étranger